we're starting the shower off with
Amanda in Virginia hi Amanda welcome to
the show hi Dave hi Kristi thank you for
taking my call
my question today is in regards to the
appropriate hat and Tommy business and
how to figure out who wears right just a
quick background my husband and I have
just started a very small online
business it's our business but I am
predominantly working on it and
investing the time in it and my husband
is focusing on medical school however we
both bring in value to the business
itself but we're trained we're
struggling to figure out how to wear
what hat and who wears that has a
husband and wife know I'm asking for
your advice okay so have you guys
already been working on the business
I'm very briefly I would flip out to
Hoffman okay how's that been going like
it was like as far as roles and and what
have you been doing up to this point so
up to this point we have had lots of
arguments and then we set the way and
said okay David you know we purchase as
not as a husband and wife but team
members I'm right from there we don't
know how to do it we're trying to figure
out who has the leadership role there's
kind of this tug-of-war of who who who
has the final say so and then we do we
just drive to like unifier with each
other but we don't have that quite
figured out okay well this is this is
interesting I actually really like this
because it's an interesting dynamic to
talk about it from a husband-wife
perspective but also like you said as a
from a business perspective so just on a
real practical sense a really easy
starting point in terms of your roles I
would say to sit down with your husband
and y'all kind of identify okay here are
the strengths that I have you Amanda
here are the strengths that he has and
go ahead and figure out what those are
what are your sweet spot the things that
give you energy that come effortless to
you that are fun for you man I'm excited
to do that to check that off that's
going to kind of fall in my lane because
you're gonna have the most fun in your
business when you're staying in your
strengths the quality is gonna be the
highest of the business when each person
staying and their strengths now even
after you do that there's gonna be a
whole lot of things that you still have
to do that may not fall and your
strengths or isn't really fun for you
isn't fun for him
those are the types of things you just
have a conversation and divided up based
on what the week is what the month is
what you know his schedule is with
medical school that type of thing
but as far as the final call this is an
interesting dynamic so I'll tell you my
husband I one of the the kind of
practices we have in our marriage
because we'll disagree on purchases or a
parent can just you know in marriage you
disagree on things what we do is we lean
into the conflict we lean into the
discomfort we never say well I'm gonna
go by that you don't disagree on the
final call or I got this paycheck this
week so I'm gonna we don't move forward
on a decision that affects both of us
until we're on the same page and that
may take some work to wrestle through it
may take some work to say okay let's get
to the root what's your fear here what's
your concern here is at the time is that
the money is that the what's going on
with our children that works for us but
I think that if you and your husband sit
down in figure okay here's our
decision-making process here here's
here's your fears here's the thing we
keep running up against that will give
you a framework to work with them
without it being a hierarchy that feels
awkward because you're married I'm
hearing you say you're doing all the
work and he still wants to be the boss
is that what's going on tell us the
truth Amanda you're doing all the work
and he wants to be the boss because he
because he's the husband it's not
because he's the husband I think this is
something that he has had a long a
desire to do but he doesn't do it he's
in med school yeah they were doing all
the work aren't you yeah he lost his
vote okay you're the CEO of this
organization he's the husband of the CEO
he has a husband's input like my wife
does has a wife's input of the she's the
wife of the CEO her little bud is not
down here working 16 hours a day like I
am and so she does not get to come down
here and interfere when we order copier
paper but that's how y'all set it up
like Amanda is that how you want I mean
is that how you're setting it up is that
the expectation
that way but at the same time Dave
that's exactly what's going on is that
I'm putting most time in and again he
definitely has a role in this I
definitely mean he's got a big intellect
and a big ego he's going to med school
so he's really smart he's a really smart
guy he's probably got some wonderful
additions that he could throw in as a
consultant but he don't get to be in
charge here what's his role right now
you said he's got a role he's got a role
what's his role what does he do right
now besides telling you what good yeah
so this is something he's definitely
like this is part of his decision he
wanted to do this a couple years ago and
asked me to be a part of it and I said
yes so as far as his role is I need him
to figure out all the numbers aspects of
things and do worksheets and things like
that and where I'm going out and I'm
actually bringing in those products and
I'm putting some that the sweat and I
guess you could say okay if I was gonna
if I was going to buy your business from
you who would I hire to do what you're
doing what would we call them what are
you the CEO okay the president what
would I hire him to do he's the CFO
managing the numbers and giving input on
the business decisions from the CFO seat
am I missing something the chief
financial officer the day-to-day
operations of the business the marketing
ideas the product conceptions he's
speaking into them you are taking that
advice and your own ideas and spinning
up all the work am I missing something
no but the only thing is like this is
still our business and we could still
have that separation I guess you can say
and still it can be considered our
business oh I didn't say that's fine
okay listen take this out you have you
got a pencil handy draw three circles
that overlap like like Olympic rings
okay a Venn diagram okay one of them
says owner one of them says family and
the other one says business member or
employee okay it all you are all three
of those okay he is all three of those
but when he is standing back and as an
owner speaking into this he's
interfering in the daily at day to day
operations if the owner tries to run the
business from the owners chair instead
of from the CEOs chair it gets that's
where you're getting your conflict
that's where the hats are coming off and
so he needs to adopt a board of
directors type position as an owner and
so my wife is an owner of this business
she speaks into this business you know
when she wants to but again she doesn't
come down and interfere in the
day-to-day operations she big decisions
like Christie said she's in on big
decisions we don't buy a piece of you
know fourteen million dollar piece of
ground like we did a while back without
her speaking into it do you think this
is a good idea as an owner but then the
actual execution of the development of
that property and putting a building on
it she didn't know how he did it because
she's not involved and she shouldn't be
in the day-to-day tactical and she's not
down here interfering while people are
trying to get their work done which is
what's happening here so so Dave you
pointed out what you heard that she's
doing on the work and he's you know want
to make decisions what I'm hearing is
this is what we're talking about right
here what Dave's saying is the
conversation you need to have Amanda
because I'd be willing to bet he doesn't
know that if this is the setup if this
is what's going on he thinks it's his
idea and he needs the guy with the
numbers yeah he's a smart guy
and so she's supposed to take away get
from we gotta reset expectations in line
with what we're unpacking here what
Dave's unpacking but we gotta you gotta
sit down with him and talk about that
absolutely exactly so I think the I
think you're right so you know the the
fact is you have identified that you
have a problem and the way we function
around here is we say are you
functioning as an owner are you
functioning as the CEO in this
conversation or are you functioning as a
family member in this organization okay
Rachael Cruise is one of the owners of
this business
she also functions as a Ramsey
personality and she also functions as a
family member of the Ramseys and you
have to stay you have to decide when
we're having a conversation which one of
those are we
husband-and-wife conversation or are we
having a CEO to Remzi personality
conversation we having a father-daughter
conversation a Papa Dave to the daughter
to the mother of my grandbabies or am i
talking to one of my Ramsey
personalities as the CEO and that
changes the tone the process the
decision-making flow when you get your
hats straightened out and that's what
that Venn diagram will help you do good
call good question this is the Dave
Ramsey show